or if you're teaching our children and
you're not free to do your job because
the only way anybody can gauge you is by
a number on a standardized test not just
freedom from freedom from government
freedom from taxes but freedom to live a
life of your choosing which only happens
if we have good government good
government that secures freedom just as
much as bad government of any size
infringes on that freedom let's go out
there and remind everybody how freedom
works security or patriotism belongs to
one side of the eye especially right now
we're the ones who know there's a lot
more to security than putting up a wall
from sea to shining sea we know the
security includes cyber security I'm not
sure a lot of people in charge right now
even understand security in the face of
a rising tide of global violent white
nationalism and by the way let's talk
about what might be the great security
issue of our time
the Emergency Operations Center of our
city twice in two years the first time
was a thousand-year flood and the second
time was a 500 year flood so either I
gotta go start playing the odds because
I got amazing luck or something is
changing around us and we're not even
having a contest between who's climate
plan is better because the other side
can't bring itself to admit that this is
debris so let's call climate what it is
climate security a life-and-death issue
for our generation and ensure our
security then we've got to make sure we
had the right kind of democracy
democracy should be a dirty word our
democratic republic is an elegant system
but lately it hasn't been quite
democratic enough it's not Democratic
enough if legitimate voters are denied
the opportunity to vote because one side
thinks is a matter of political strategy
that they're better off and here people
are able to vote I don't think we're as
Democratic as we ought to be if dollars
can out both people and if the only way
to fix that is a constitutional
amendment that isn't that what the
amendment process
you really want to call ourselves a
Democratic Republic maybe we're going to
do away with the system where districts
are drawn such the politicians get to
choose their voters sending the other
way around
[Applause]
and with this new vocabulary I think we
can reach people who for any number of
reasons
may have stopped listening what we have
to say but we have to actually get that
out there and do it we have to do in
communities of every stripe of every
size red and blue because where is it
written
they had a so-called red state a red
county has to be read forever
they didn't start out Republican they
don't have to be Republican in the
future we got to get out there and talk
to them and that's what this process is
all about for us I know that these are
challenging times but the congresswoman
had it right spring is here and as grim
as it might be as hard as it is to take
our eye off what we see on cable because
grotesque things have the quality of
drawing your eye
what matters is our everyday life and
our everyday life is subject to the
decisions that are being made by people
with power over our life and that's what
elections are all about so we've got to
change and it's an act of hope and so is
helping somebody run for office
[Music]
I'm gonna need you to help spread that
word not just that I belong at the table
I think we got that far but this is the
way that we can begin to win not just an
election but an air
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]